actors are sometimes
undisciplined enough not to go home and
go to sleep at night and learn their
lines and they go out they cannot Act
without knowing dialogue if you have to
think about anything when you're acting
you cannot work on the emotion it's
happened on every film you really
there's not much you can do about them
you can fire them on day one when you
get into day 12 you know you can
threaten them you can cajole them you
can try to appeal to their sense of what
reputation they're creating among the
crew and so you wind up say with this
particular Factor you know maybe doing
30 takes of something then the guy gets
back to America and if he's nice he says
oh boy it's the only such a
perfectionist he does a hundred takes on
every scene I had to do this thing you
know a hundred times so the 30 becomes a
hundred and of course they never say why
you did so many takes I don't do a lot
of things when it's good